hello everyone and thanks for coming my
name is Jessica Palmer and I will be
talking about using Python and touch
designer to make interactive experiments
I'm originally from Toronto Canada but I
moved to Berlin about two years ago and
I just can't seem to leave because of
all of the brain science I mostly worked
for dr. Petra British erté in the
experimental neurology department our
current project is a SDK and app project
which uses neurofeedback and some brain
visualizations my background is an art
and design but slowly over the past two
years I've become a developer I not sure
how it happened
and I have about one year's Python
experience my favorite tool is touch
designer what is touch designer it's a
real-time visual development platform
for Windows you mostly get around using
Python and you can use Python
exclusively but if you're into it you
can also use C++ and you can also use
shader language to write directly to the
GPU it's super popular with VJs and
projection mapping but that's not the
only use of touch designer there's
people who are using touch designer to
combine data science and every other
type of science and art to make an
interactive experiments and experiences
this is the work of matthew regan and
he's a super favorite of mine on the
left is a clock which is made out of the
sampling of a video in a room over time
the outside rings represent long time
durations like months or years and as
you get towards the center you get down
to seconds in nanoseconds the result is
an image of a room over time seen at
once as it's being created the image on
the right is a sampling of images pulled
from different threads on 4chan you
might be able to guess from these colors
with the most popular images are
unfortune but don't think about it too
much the most well-known and most
well-loved work done in touch designer
is the
collaborative work between Amon Tobin
and the v-square team in this example we
have a 3d structure which is being
mapped with animated video which is
being driven by data which is extracted
from the computer that m1 Tobin is
making his music on I just want to point
out here that this isn't a simple audio
in like a microphone which is having
like bandpass filters applied to it and
the audio dynamics extracted afterwards
this is messages from his computer that
represent the different instruments and
the different layers of music and
samples these are being interpreted by
the v-square team and turned into
generative animations and video clips
which are being triggered by different
behavior of the music playing so it
creates a different experience every
time in this example the images on the
both left and right are taken from data
from a Kinect using the depth sensor on
the left the images are the data is
being turned into a 3d geometry which is
describing the form of the performer
while she's moving she's even taking a
back stage to the animation you can see
here in shadow in the foreground and her
actual performance body is the image
created from the data on the second
image the same information from the
depth sensor is being turned into a
points cloud which describes her motion
over time in the space and also
interacting with the bodies of other
performers sometimes they connect even
confuses them for the same person which
is interesting I just want to point out
that all of this is happening in real
time with Python this is like being
calculated probably about 60 times a
second and I take this for granted
because when I first started learning
Python I was also learning touch
designer at the same time I just thought
this is how you do I didn't realize
until later when I was watching my
colleagues tried to draw brain data
traces in MATLAB that usually these
things don't happen so quickly
I love touch designer because it
supports my workflow it's fast and
intuitive and everything that I do I can
see happen immediately including the
errors here's an example of just some
normal Python script that I wrote it's
not important that you can't read it but
I just want to point out that this is a
linear workflow from top to bottom
reading instructions it's not exactly
how
my brain works and we're how I'm
thinking about when I think about
projects this is a little bit closer to
how I think about building something a
network diagram it's still not perfect
we have the inputs on one side which are
being organized by modules which go into
instructions and then those get relayed
to the different assets and at the end
you see the final product I'm going to
show you a video of what it's like to
work in touch designer I don't know what
to call this exactly maybe I'll call it
a real-time inception type Network it's
a node and wire system it's a hybrid of
visual programming and text based
programming and it's network diagrams
all the way down in this way I can
visually organize different behaviors
and different assets and different
modules in physical locations and move
them around and reassemble them to
create new machines touch designer is a
complete environment you have everything
you need to make your project right away
from start to finish you make the
prototype you write the instructions you
do the experiments and you run the
experiment in touch designer it's easy
to make scalable and reusable components
and it's ready to go with about a
million inputs and outputs you have
access to real-time 3d graphics through
Python alone and the full power of your
GPU the workflow is however you want it
you don't have to make a crazy spaghetti
network diagram like I made you can keep
it nice and neat and tidy or just text
if you like you don't have to be a
wizard to make very adequate things but
if you are a wizard holy crap
you can already whip up something
totally awesome with the Python that you
already know for me it was suddenly I
was like putting on a mech suit suddenly
I had access to everything and I could
build what I wanted almost right away so
in the early times someone in the lab
asked me to make a simple experiment to
expose subjects to a random sampling of
audio clips and she also wanted to
record the brain data at the same time
and she also want to give the subject
instructions in a particular sequence
which is automated
and she wanted to run this experiment
over and over again about 50 times a day
we made this experiment together in an
afternoon before I continue I'm going to
give a quick overview about how touch
designer works
it's an Oden wire system nodes are
called operators or ops for short and
they have very cute names and colors
which represent the type of data that
each of them handle only operators of
the same class can connect to each other
with wires so an image to an image or a
video to a video actually video can go
to an image but a 3d object to a 3d
object a text object to a text object
but you can also convert them between
each other so for example on the Left we
have a gradient top or a normal texture
being turned into a data channel with a
chopped and then being converted to get
into a table of values so the operator
on the far end is a description of the
original image with a row for each pixel
in the image and the different columns
are the RGB a channels this is a noise
chopped which I'm going to use as an
example and it exists in the visual
operating world with a parameters page
attached which you can start using right
away to change how the noise works but
also every operator can be accessed with
Python through different flags and
different methods etc there's about a
million this is just an example where
you use Python to grab all the data from
this noise channel the flags will change
the behavior of this operator in the
visual environment so for example you
can tell this operator to be bypassed in
the network i I'm not trying to sell
touch designer I just want to get you
excited about all the cool stuff you can
make with it and all the data that you
can gather and visualize and all the
ways you can interact with data but
obviously I really love touch designer
and let me count the ways so in this
chart are a few examples of the inputs
and outputs which are already available
to you in the in the graphical
environment so you place one operator
into the field and you have
access to all the data on the Kinect
camera for example you don't have to
understand how the Kinect works you
don't have to read the Kinect
documentation or understand the SDK you
can use the Python you already know to
get information from the Kinect camera
and start using it same goes for out so
you Karen out your project to any
virtual reality which is supported by
open VR including the oculus rift and
the HTC vive it also has tools ready for
you to communicate with your own custom
devices to for both in and out and it's
ready for particular systems like
commercial lighting rigs and lasers just
to show you how easy this is to work
with different inputs this is an example
where I'm using five different inputs at
the same time all of these are supported
by touch designer right away
you can drag wires from one component to
another to change the flow of the data
but in this case I'm going to use a
switch and some buttons because it's
more tidy so this is just displaying
normal keyboard activity this is
displaying the gyroscope on my phone
whether or not I'm shaking it and I can
use the touchscreen as a toggle I've set
it up so that every single one of these
inputs can go into the same visualizer
which is just some simple text and
particles and also I can move all of
these components to a data saving module
at the top if I want to record
everything that happened this case I'm
using a MIDI controller called the op1
and you just to get which keys in which
pots I'm using in this case I'm using
the muse which is a commercial eg
headset and I'm just printing out the
alpha and beta and if I relax enough it
will print out if I'm relaxed
it's really hard to relax in this case
I'm using the Kinect camera and using
the facial tracking to determine whether
my face is being tracked at all and
which face I'm making I'm going to show
you later the one line of code I used to
make this happen it's this all you have
to do is ask the Kinect for which facial
expression and then do basically
whatever you want I'm really excited
about this the best part is that there's
Python everywhere in touch resigner so
many different opportunities to use a
lot or a little bit so in this case you
can write python directly into the
parameters fields on in the visual
environment so in this case I'm using a
module which returns how relaxed or
focused the subject is to make a dancer
move faster or slower based on this
information so I just took that thing
and put it into the speed of a single
video clip which is one of these dancers
in this scene that's super fast you can
also write Python as normal in a data
operator or in the terminal and other
operators or other scripts can execute
these entirely or in the case of mods
just call a particular function some
operators have events such as this timer
and it's quite handy because it already
comes attached to with this attach that
with all the possible events of this
timer so for example the timer will know
when it's done when it's being reset
when it's ready when it's finished if
it's looping and you can just inject
tiny bits of Python into that particular
event to cause a particular thing to
happen you can also send data to touch
designer with python news
network sockets and it comes in to touch
designer all formatted and ready to use
so you can also send data out of touch
design and with OSCE or UDP or TCP IP by
just placing an operator and sending a
message over that type of network is as
easy as saying this network operator dot
send and then your message if you wanted
you can decide never to place an
operator with a mouse ever you can
ignore the visual environment completely
all operators can be created or
destroyed with Python alone and on the
chart over here we have examples of some
of the ways you can modify operators via
Python and you can also modify them at
creation or after creation by addressing
them by their operator name so in this
case we have a piece of text which
creates a sphere object called my sphere
and then the second text object we have
something that destroys any object by
the name of my sphere
there are also some Python modules
automatically in touch designer that are
pretty handy store and fetch is
interesting because it's a fast and easy
way to store anything as a global
variable including an entire operator or
an entire network of operators you can
also talk to operators by their name
using me dot digits or parent digits
parent digit refers to that operators
place in the hierarchy so operators
above it and below it so this is handy
when you're using replication and you
have an unknown amount of operators or a
very large amount of operators with
python scripts attached to them and you
just want to know what the name is in
order to perform a particular function
function on the operator so save 100
noise channels and you want them to all
be unique you can make the seed of that
noise equal to it's me dot digits in
touch designer you can use as much or as
little python as you want it's equally
possible to create a project entirely
with Python as it is to create one
without you might be asking what you can
do with this and basically anything you
can hack some devices you have lying
around you can make a game you can
collect data on mass you can prototype
software for me working on the app and
SDK right now
it's much easier for me to prototype
something in a day in touch designer
than spend two weeks doing it in Xcode
if I want to find out how if a game
mechanic is fun or not I can invest a
little bit less time improve it before I
spend all that time building it you can
also turn your data skills into art and
you can design and execute complete
science experiments and you can make
something that's a little bit of both
I'm not going to talk about a project I
worked on with some brain scientists
that share it a here in Berlin and
Baycrest home in Toronto my virtual
dream is both in our installation and a
science experiment my virtual dream is a
collective neurofeedback experience
where four subjects could control layers
of video with their brain and also music
I worked on the BCI I worked with a BCI
team to make something that was
simultaneously a collective interactive
experience but also a novel way to study
the brain don't make a noise in my
virtual dream 4 subjects were fitted
with commercial EEG headsets we wanted
to collect data to see if people learned
how to control their brain state either
relax or focus within the short time
frame of 20 minutes we also wanted to
test and verify if neurofeedback could
be used as a reliable input did the
subjects feel in control of the dream
and how does the data compare here
gathered in the wild as it does the data
that we collect in the lab
you might recognize this from the first
video this is my control panel for my
virtual dream I can monitor the subjects
and the progress of the software and
just in case something breaks change the
settings in my case this is the top
layer of my network and all the guts are
underneath the first challenge was
getting the brain data from the headsets
the brain computer interface team first
acquired the data from the headset and
determined the state of the subjects
which was where they were in a scale of
relaxation to focus this was pre
processed and sent to me over network
I'm using a replicator here because I
designed the software to include any
number of subjects we settled on for
later but we could change this in the
future here I organized and defined the
data and what to do with the data a
player is defined by their score their
color the video of music that they
control I can also define if they are on
a team in the case of large volumes of
players in the past we had up to 20 and
we've discussed going up to 100 players
have momentary an accumulative measure
momentary is their immediate state at
this moment which fluctuates wildly it's
hard to control cumulative as a second
measure which is a description of their
state in general more points are awarded
to cumulative if the more they maintain
a relaxed or focused state both of these
these measures are used for the players
to tell them about how they're doing and
to give them constant feedback when you
zoom out of the network it looks like
this I think of it as a machine because
I can swap out parts at any time I can
make new components which change the
entire behavior of the experiment and I
can take components from this experiment
and make new experiments it's organized
by function and it's color-coded there
are different areas of the network for
connections player identity how data is
saved how the audio and video assets are
classified and how different behaviors
of the program work and interact with
each other the
second challenge was graphics I wanted
to keep it modular and scalable I wanted
to be able to add more scenes and
animations easily and I wanted to be
able to do the same for the music I
wanted everything to reflect the state
of the player and I wanted to control
everything with Python scripts to make
it automatic here's an example of a bank
of dream images that were used to make
the entire presentation each component
contains all the animation layers and
all the special behaviors of each scene
they're given an ID and a classification
and tables so that I can easily refer to
them anywhere in the project and grab a
dream by its name or type after all of
that I was able to write this script
this is the dream selection logic and
it's called every frame when I need a
new dream this happens maybe two or four
anywhere between two and four times for
each set of subjects for a study to know
the mood of the dreamers this is an
amalgamation of all the subject states
which is either relaxed focused or
somewhere in between
then a set is made of all possible
dreams which fit into this category
after this I subtract the dreams which
have already been played so I don't get
repeats and then I select a dream from
random from that set and add that to the
dream setlist so that it doesn't get
played again and returned the idea of
that dream operators which handle dream
scenes know them by their ID so I can
cue them with the script script anywhere
in the project and when it all comes
together like this it feels like magic
the entire 20-minute experience for the
four subjects is triggered by a series
of daisy chain timers I remember when I
showed you the event handlers on the
timer chop where you can put Python
instructions it's basically this a lot I
did this so that I could edit the length
of the scenes from a single table to
adjust how the whole experience played
out maybe I wanted it much shorter or
maybe I wanted the intro to be really
long so that someone could give a talk
at the beginning or maybe I just want it
to run really quickly so I could debug
it after the dream is selected it's
cross blended with the previous one and
here I made a custom crossfade component
since I wanted something fancy it then
goes through a bunch of special effects
processing and then it gets added to one
video still at the end of the network
funneling down and this is happy all of
this stuff is happening 60 times a
second here's a snippet from one of the
timers when the timer it's done it will
execute the next stream and trigger the
crossfade there's also a function called
shriek and shriek is a special function
close to my heart this leads to the
third channel this is a challenge this
is a science experiment and we want to
look at the data after raw data is being
saved by the brain computer interface
team but they want markers from me so
they can go through the data later and
find out what the subjects were
experiencing when the data was being
saved I also want to be able to look at
the text log so that can read what
happened and recreate dreams just from
text I also want to monitor the
experience while it's happening shriek
is an elegant solution or my elegant
solution it does everything at the same
time I can send marks over Network so
that the BC I can log it on their
computer and it also saves the events to
my computer and possibly it could do
other things at the same time people
wanted to change the marks all the time
so tables again was the easiest solution
on the Left we just have the index for
every event that could happen during the
experiment and the second one is the
human readable string that I wanted and
the last one is the mark that the BCI
team wanted a colleague Carol eNOS
Toshio has taken the data collected from
MBD and started to interpret it there's
still a lot to work to be done but in
this graph it depicts the subjects
ability to use a single type metric
relaxation versus the absence of
relaxation and the purple depict depicts
the subjects ability to use a dual type
metric which is relaxation versus focus
which are not mutually exclusive which
may explain why it's more difficult
there's still lots to learn and it will
probably never end and I hope that this
talked helped you imagine how you might
use touch designer to make your own
experiments a great place to learn more
and probably all you ever need to know
are the tutorials of matthew regan
there's also lots of really great
documentation and a place to start with
touch designer on their wiki
I can talk about this all day every day
so if you have any questions you can
send me an email or find me on LinkedIn
also for a long night of the sciences
we're going to do a demonstration of MBD
and our brain modes app and dr. Petra
Ritter will be giving talks on the
virtual brain which is an open source
full brain simulator thanks for
listening and enjoy the rest of the
great talks at PI data very much for
this interesting talk and now will we
have time for any questions okay um I'll
start can you please I'm talking if it
is it like open source or how can you um
get this the fancy software you can get
it for free to use right away but the
resolution is capped and it is missing
like a few features but you can
basically do everything that I just
showed you in the free version I think
the educational version costs around 300
which will allow you to use the software
and events where you're accepting money
payments and then there's like a super
fancy fancy version which costs about
two thousand that you can lock your
network so that no one can see what you
did in the case that you want to take
what you did and sell it to like a
museum or another laboratory or
something and you want to protect your
IP but basically it's free for messing
around
the headset that we're using is called
amused by a company called interaction
and it's a four-channel eg with two
grounding sensors in the front so it's
very minimal and crude and this costs
about 300 Canadian dollars I think which
is basically pennies and euros I think
and but I think the most capable EG
headset available for commercial use is
the Emotiv EPOC which is a 16 channel
headset and I believe just normal this
costs about 400 euros but if you want to
have like access to all the EEG you have
to fork out for the SDK and we're
running about 700 you can also make your
own you can I think it's called open BCI
and you can get instructions on how to
make your own from scratch okay thank
you very much for listening
and that's breathe tank um Jessica yeah